April yeah get my lunch for me please
okay like order you something no get it
from there this is some kind of weird
power trip please thank you that'll be
all you're welcome
[Music]
working late yep
and I'll have the number 8 that's a
party platter that serves 12 people I
know what I'm about son go ahead run let
me have it
oh wait I'll do it for you I told you so
Leslie this is what happens when the
government interferes with business
government is bad business is good
free-market capitalism is the only way
Leslie it moves our country forward it's
what makes America great and England ok
and France terrible I'd like capitalism
I'd love competition I'm more
competitive than you I don't think so I
think settle down no sell up cuz the
bills been paid and I've paid it and
I've won look the point is there has to
be a way for the government to help
places that add community value but
don't necessarily rake in the money
there is not the free market is a jungle
as beautiful and brutal and should be
left alone when a business fails it dies
and a new better one takes its place
just let business be business and
government be government sure all right
party time I would suggest sticking
around and watching him eat it cuz it
only takes 4 minutes and it's pretty
amazing
these will not be necessary ok let's
begin the barbecue Oh No everyone meet
your meat well in my opinion not enough
people have looked at their dinner in
the eyes and considered the circle of
life this is your dinner his name is Tom
Byrne seriously no I understand that
it's hilarious but that is his given
Christian name
Tom is very smart and incredibly loyal
he's basically a dog a dog we're going
to cook chew and swallow dude there's
kids around here good point which one of
you youngsters wants to help me drain
the blood from this animal you do a good
job I'll give you the bladder you can
blow it up for a fun play ball hey Ron
you're not gonna slaughter that pig here
are you not to worry I have a permit
this just says I can do what I want I am
the director of the parks department and
this is a park it's not a parks thing
it's against like three laws and a dozen
health code
fine barbecue is postponed until I can
go pick up some meat from the food and
stuff let's go Tom no Pig Tom I couldn't
care less about the commendation
but Indianapolis is home to Charles
Mulligan's Steakhouse the best damn
Steakhouse in the damn State
I have taken a picture of every steak
I've ever eaten there June 2004
porterhouse medium-rare Bearnaise sauce
January 2000 they call this one the
enforcer February 96 a steak ribeye the
whiskey Lagavulin 16 the lady next to me
a [ __ ] specifically my ex-wife Tammy ok
this is this is the first time I ever
went there oh just a kid history began
on July 4th 1776 everything before that
was a mistake
Dianne suggested we tag along to London
for a honeymoon I agreed because my love
for her Trump's my hatred for Europe
then she hit a phase of morning sickness
that knocked her for a loop and decided
to stay home but she insisted I go and
take pictures for her all of this could
have been avoided if we'd followed my
plan for a honeymoon a steak dinner
a glass of Lagavulin whiskey than
vigorous lovemaking for two hours and
we're both asleep by 8:30 Donna this is
crazy
typhoon is an artist and the human head
is a canvas just listen you're gonna cut
the man's hair you're gonna charge him
$8 it'll take you four minutes so just
shut up
and make the man look like this fine so
typhoon what do you like to do for fun
I'm writing an electronic opera about
Brittany Murphy and I do the chandelier
design for my friends direct puppet show
no further questions
all I really want to do is dance except
lately all the good warehouse waves are
filled with the Eurotrash Eurotrash I
don't like that it is indeed a garbage
Continent yes oh my god I had the worst
time in Berlin last May everyone was on
their stupid bikes I was like ill please
talk more about how you hate Europe and
bicycles it's really good to see you run
you've aged horribly you son of a [ __ ]
and didn't oh my god what is your
problem I did okay that what you want to
eat we're fine we're fine
please when you're metal in someone's
personal life it's just so rewarding
you
this is land good morning Jerry
that is a beautiful sweater vest April
you look like you could use $20 am i
right
why cuz you're a kid kids always need
money I need money ah that's why you're
my favorite Tom when Tiger Woods feels
invincible he wears a red shirt and
black pants good morning deputy Ron
wears the same thing after he's had sex
I'm a simple man I like pretty
dark-haired women and breakfast food but
this stock photo I bought at a framing
store isn't real today I got the real
thing
a naked Tammy made me breakfast this
morning I should have taken a picture of
it this isn't a steak why would you call
it that on your menu and I know to tell
you man just give me all the bacon and
eggs you have wait wait I worry what you
just heard was give me a lot of bacon
and eggs what I said was give me all the
bacon and eggs you have do you
understand
Ron you've been sweating in here all day
are you drinking any fluids yes plumbing
no you need to drink water usually I
take it neat but I will make an
exception in the name of Health last
Lana watched a movie with Diane and the
girls in which an orange fish is
separated from his father the children
were sniffling which I believed to be
due to the sad nature of the film I was
wrong you need to take off those layers
rehydrate and go to the doctor thank you
for your concern I will be fine
please turn the thermostat up to 90 and
leave me alone Ron this isn't safe I'm a
grown man I have had a cold before I
need no help so if you don't mind
that seems about right so while they
repaint the lines in the parking lot
we're asking everyone to do street
parking
I'm not street parking my Mercedes well
everyone is I'm doing it because nobody
wants to steal a Saturn alright moving
on to recycling
UK run just a little tooth pain I'm fine
continue okay each department will be
getting blue bins do you need to go to
the dentist Ron I don't like dentists
just a second oh I'm sorry everybody
what were we talking about recycling
dentist pulled the tooth out yesterday
but it's always a good idea to
demonstrate to your co-workers that you
are capable of withstanding a tremendous
amount of pain plus it's always fun to
see Tom faint
you